[Música]
bueno desde que el hombre busca presente
sobre la tierra desde que tenemos
constancia de su existencia
ha quedado grabado la escultura como
preste su relación y su lucha cuando
grandes movidos
no es por casualidad que las primeras
escrituras de la
la civilización sumeria
se basen en las epopeyas de gilgamesh
que junto a su amigo en kilo además de
otras muchas cosas lo que hicieron fue
matar al todo celeste con una espada y
con una sábana blanca
de los testículos del todo salieron los
generales y de
su sangre salió de todas las vides las
vides y las niñas
y la verdad es que todo es la lucha del
hombre con héctor ha sido siempre
mitológica
y se ha transformado en un viento
sacrificial que ha formado parte
fundamental de la cultura mediterránea
esa evento sacrificial ha ido
evolucionando con las distintas culturas
con las distintas sociedades hasta
llegar a lo que es actualmente la
corrida de toros la máxima expresión la
más evolucionada del recto sacrificial
todos los principios de siglo hay un
conflicto de ideas todos los principios
de siglo se lucha por modelos distintos
de sociedad que cada uno tiene en su
imaginación una que olvidar que en el
pasado siglo que fue final del milenio
empezó con dos de realidades
y además
a cabo como el siglo quizá el de más
desarrollo de la civilización
así de siglo de la tecnología y en este
principio de siglo y de milenio la
confrontación de ideas es tremenda
brutal el mundo está viviendo una
convulsión el mundo está viviendo una
confrontación tremenda de ideas
completamente distintas
todo esto se agrava con la pandemia de
la cepa con 1.019 de la vida que ha
hecho que el mundo se transforme ha
parado las economías
la actividad de los distintos países ya
ha transformado la vida y ha destrozado
también vidas negocios trayectorias de
todo
es el momento de reinventar es el
momento de renacer
el primero el nacimiento que tenemos
constancia
fue cuando después de la oscura época de
la edad media
el hombre miró a los valores del mundo
antiguo y se reinventó
entonces estos valores del mundo antiguo
estaban representados principalmente por
la cultura griega y romana la cultural
'eco' romana que a su vez era la
heredera de toda la cultura oriental
esos valores antiguos esos valores del
mundo del tipo sirvieron para que la
humanidad
al fase de que fuera desarrollando y
alcanzan alcanzase un nivel de
desarrollo
que gozamos actualmente del mundo
occidental vive en unos estados de
estabilidad de confort o de confort de
confort y de riquezas jamás conocidos y
de paz
estamos seguros un periodo del pastel -
prácticamente la segunda guerra mundial
en toda europa occidental quizás uno de
los más longevos los periodos de paz
cogemos
e
la verdad es que la medida
de l'humanité este renacimiento fue el
humanismo el humanismo
se basaba en que el hombre era la medida
de todas las cosas pero el hombre en su
soberbia
olvida dos principios fundamentales
agrediendo al planeta
y haciendo
acciones que nos pueden llevar hacia la
destrucción del planeta organizacional y
el planeta bueno pues ha subido la
temperatura está levantando pandemias
enfermedades
ciclones escaparatismo o simulaciones
etcétera etcétera
y creo que ha llegado el momento de
renacer de reinventarse y hay que buscar
esos valores que nos han hecho como
somos que nos han hecho ser como somos
esos valores son precisamente esos que
guardaba en un activo como decía sánchez
dragó la tauromaquia es lo único que nos
queda amigo del mundo activo
cuáles son esos valores como el honor la
responsabilidad la valentía el
pensamiento común es decir
la generosidad
antes de poner el nuestro aluminio
y por supuesto
y luchar por conseguir lo que en cierta
medida parece imposible
el grito es artificial del tono guarda
todos esos valores
es una ofrenda que el hombre hace de uno
de sus grandes tesoros es el toro bravo
el dios pierde desde la naturaleza
fijaros que la todo marc ya procede de
todas las culturas solares en las que el
rey sol era rojo y torea torró es decir
el sol en la tierra
entonces la ofrenda consistía en una de
nuestras cosas más valoradas más
preciadas que el acto no ofrecerse
orador dioses poniendo la misma la única
exigencia
que tiene que tener el torero es que
tiene que ofrecer su vida a ponerle al
juego para que el reto se consuma
la única
el único billete que tiene que pagar el
torero
es que pueden pérdida de su vida en el
envite de sacrificio o en la postulación
del sacrificio
por eso la tauromaquia está cuajada de
esos valores eternos de esos valores que
nos han hecho ser como somos
una corrida de toros
es una muestra de valor de generosidad
de inteligencia
de gracia
de belleza de todos esos valores que
siempre ha apreciado el ser humano que
los ha hecho mejores
cuando venimos a este mundo no conocemos
absolutamente nada de dónde vamos
y nuestro nuestros padres y su cultura
nos dan las guías por las que nos
tenemos que orientar en esta travesía
que es la vida
nos dan esas guías a través de su
cultura que nos dan la lengua la
religión las costumbres culinarias
educación y los que hemos tenido la
suerte en criarlos en la cultura del
toro
tenemos un accésit completo de cómo debe
ser ese comportamiento y cuáles son las
consecuencias de nuestros actos
en una corrida de toros está condensada
toda la historia del mundo mediterráneo
en dos horas que dura la pérdida o en 20
minutos que es la línea en todo
y además de estar condensada toda la
historia del mediterráneo están
y empresas están escritas no están
representadas de una forma real y
auténtica
todas las soluciones a los problemas que
la vida cotidiana nos plantea
por eso
soy defensor absoluto y os ánimo
a que busques sin complejos
y sin prejuicios dentro de lo lento
sacrificial del toro todo lo que tiene
de grande todo lo que tiene de
majestuoso
y todo lo que tiene de formativo el que
un hombre ofrezca su vida su vida a los
dioses
para que el sacrificio el rito
sacrificial del toro se consuma
la corrida de toros la fiesta de los
toros es el gran regalo que le hace
españa a la humanidad por eso os ánimo
aunque os acercáis a ella a que la
disfrutéis pisado
salvador y sepáis sacar todas las
enseñanzas
magníficas
que 20 minutos de lidia
guardan en su seno